ja hat sie haben gerade gesagt sie sind
wütend aber was werden sie jetzt
persönlich unternehmen dass jemand wie
nikolas löbel nicht noch einen weiteren
tag ins parlament zurück kommt auch
georg nüßlein hat angekündigt zwar aus
ihrer fraktion rauszugehen aber er will
ins zurück ins parlament geht es darum
noch mal weiter zu verdienen noch ein
bisschen pension abzukassieren was
werden sie tun wenn sie die beiden das
nächste mal sehen
also worum es ihm geht müssen sie die
beiden fragen
ich kann ihnen sagen wir haben sofort
uns dazu geäußert wir haben ganz klar
gesagt so ein verhalten ist unanständig
und es beschämt uns und wenn man so die
hand aufgehalten hat dann muss man sein
mandat niederlegen armin laschet ist
heute noch mal in aller deutlichkeit
gesagt ich hab's als cdu-generalsekretär
entsprechend kommentiert und ich weiss
ich spreche hier für die ganze partei
beide müssen jetzt den schritt gehen das
mandat niederlegen nicht nur aus der
bundestagsfraktion austreten und das
haben wir in aller deutlichkeit gesagt
also sie sagen sofort austreten und
nicht noch bis august weiter machen
natürlich jetzt sofort die menschen
verstehen es nicht man muss für seine
fehler einstehen und deswegen heißt es
jetzt das amt niederlegen legen das
mandat zurückgeben
herr klingbeil wenn sie sich diese fälle
in der union anschauen die da
hochgekommen sind in den vergangenen
tagen können sie eigentlich ausschließen
dass bei auch bei ihnen so was hoch
bleibt in der spd gehe davon aus dass
das bei uns nicht passiert dass es bei
uns keine abgeordneten gibt die sich an
einer persönlichen note situationen der
in diesem land sind persönlich
bereichern also da bin ich mir ziemlich
sicher das kann nicht ausschliessen für
die spd-fraktion kenne viele kolleginnen
und kollegen das geht in anderen
politikern er sicherlich genauso die
tagtäglich wirklich im einsatz sind die
nicht bemühen um die wahlkreise aber
niemand von denen käme auch nur im
geringsten auf die idee sich persönlich
zu bereichern
und man muss wirklich sagen das was da
jetzt mit unions kollegen passiert ist
das schadet dem vertrauen und politik
insgesamt geschadet dem
abgeordnetenmandat
deswegen ist völlig richtig dass beide
jetzt sofort ihre mandate niederlegen
müssen aber ich sage auch ganz klar die
müssen diese eine million zurück
bezahlen
diese persönliche bereicherung das ist
in die eigene tasche geflossen
dieses geld muss zurück da erwarte ich
auch dass solche summen jetzt
zurückgezahlt werden
sie sagen sie können das ausschließen
dass keiner in der spd-fraktion solche
deals abgeschlossen hat haben sie das
überprüft oder haben sie jetzt mal ihre
abgeordneten angerufen und gesagt wer da
irgendwas verdient hat jetzt alles auf
den tisch wenn es fast nicht zu meinem
selbstverständnis als abgeordneter noch
mal jeder von uns hat doch innen aber es
geht ja nicht um sie jetzt sondern es
geht ja um die gesamte spd-fraktion
weshalb ich gefragt habe wer will
ausschließen dass ist in der
spd-fraktion vorkommen er wollte immer
ich habe keine hinweise darauf ich
vertraue auch den leuten in meiner
fraktion ich gehe nicht davon aus dass
es ein solches verhalten meiner fraktion
gibt das ist schäbig was da passiert ist
das muss korrigiert werden es ist
richtig dass bei die unions fraktion
verlassen
und jetzt muss das geld auch
zurückgezahlt werden der kellner wenn
sie auf die union blicken in diesen
tagen
erstaunlicherweise hört man von der
grünen-spitze bislang nicht so wirklich
harte kritik auch an der union liegt das
daran dass sie schon
an die koalition denken überhaupt nicht
also wir haben seit einer woche hart
kritisiert und vorschläge macht ich will
noch mal sagen wir haben hier erlebt
geschäfte mit der note einer nation das
ist ungeheuerlich und ja sie sollten
sofort zurücktreten und das geld
zurückzahlen und es sind eben leider mit
sieben ja gesagt keine einzelfälle wir
haben zwei weitere fälle von
abgeordneten die seine geschäfte für
aserbaidschan gemacht haben ist es
gerade philipp am tor der letztes jahr
im zentrum eines skandals stand in
mecklenburg vorpommern zum
spitzenkandidat für die bundestagswahl
erneut jetzt am wochenende gewährte man
kann sagen gegen korruption wurde noch
kein impfstoff entwickelt doch würde ich
das sonst der unionsfraktion wirklich
empfehlen
und wir haben ja schon anfang der woche
haben wir vorschläge macht
und da würde mich freuen wenn sie merkt
sagt ja lasst uns den weg gehen wir
haben doch die union blockiert seit
jahren seit jahren blockiert sie
vorschläge für bessere kontrolle und
transparenz in der politik
wir haben montag noch mal vorgeschlagen
ein lobbyregister das ist der vorschlag
der großen koalition ist kritisiert
kommen vom bdi familienunternehmern naro
transparency international den ist das
viel zu wenig lassen sie uns
nebentätigkeiten von abgeordneten auf
heller und cent veröffentlichen
lassen sie uns karenzzeiten einführen
für regierungsmitglieder oder lassen sie
die parteienfinanzierung verändern so
dass spenden die offenlegungspflicht
viel früher greift das alles werden
vorschläge für eine offene und
transparente politik und die stellen der
abstimmung ich würde mich freuen wenn
die union dafür den weg frei macht die
grünen fordern auf heller und cent
nebentätigkeiten angeben möglicherweise
auch spenden es gab ja jetzt einige
fälle bei ihnen eben herr nüßlein den
haben wir angesprochen löbel haben sie
eigentlich sorge dass da noch weiteres
auf blockt in den nächsten tagen und was
tun sie persönlich dafür jetzt dass die
beiden um wo es um horrende summen geht
dieses geldspenden zurückzahlen oder in
irgendeiner form sagen okay das war ein
fehler wir geben dieses geld zurück
dem wir das ja offen diskutieren und
deswegen stelle ich mich auf dieser
debatte hier und ich habe damals auch
schon als es um das logic ist dagegen
gesagt ja es ist ganz wichtig dass
transparenz herrscht und man weiß welche
ab er welche lobby gruppen wie arbeiten
welchen zutritt sie auch zum parlament
haben wer ist das eigentlich und wie
viel setzen sie dort ein
und deswegen bin ich da nicht nur
persönlich sondern die unionsfraktion ja
auch mit der spd jetzt auf einem guten
weg das zu tun und auch wenn es darum
geht was es mit den nebentätigkeiten und
was ist auch mit spenden darüber kann
man diskutieren absolut was ist mit
zurück und zahlen und spenden der sohn
sie da von mir was ist mit den es so
noch was ist mit dem sumpf ziehen
660.000 euro in höhe frei 120000 euro
was ist mit den summen was ist mit den
summen um die es da jetzt geht nüßlein
und löwe was tun sie persönlich dass die
beiden das geldspenden zurückzahlen
ich kann ihnen ja sagen wir sind jetzt
gerade dabei es war das wichtigste zu
klären nämlich dass die mandate
zurückgegeben werden das ist das was die
menschen beschäftigt warum sind sie noch
mitglieder des deutschen bundestag die
menschen beschäftigt auch entschuldigen
sie mir die menschen beschäftigen auch
da sind ja wird sich demand dass sich
die politiker spricht so retten
bereichert haben wir uns aber ich muss
mich ich muss mich hier zumindest an die
regie wenden weil es sehr leise ist und
ich sie sehr schlecht verstehe wenn sie
mir dazwischenreden es ist zu leise wenn
sie ist eigentlich für sie erzählt dann
gebe ich die frage kurz einmal weiter
währenddessen bevor wir zurückgehen und
zwar in dem fall an den fdp general
volker wissing er wissen jetzt sind
fdp-abgeordnete durchaus dafür bekannt
dass einige von ihnen nebenjobs haben
dass es da leute gibt die dazu verdienen
haben sie ja schon mal nachgefragt wer
bei ihnen somit verdient hat im
massengeschäft im im geschäft was
schnelltest angeht wenn die kolleginnen
und kollegen der bundestagsfraktion
machen ihre nebentätigkeiten dieser im
rahmen ihrer beruflichen tätigkeit
ausüben ja transparent und legen das
entsprechend der regeln des deutschen
bundestages offen das was wir hier bei
der cdu csu fraktion sehen
ist ja ein ungeheuerlicher vorgang da
hat man offensichtlich in der zeit in
der die nation in einer note sich
befindet zuerst mal an seine eigenen
profit gedacht das ist zutiefst
verwerflich und ich halte das für
absolut erforderlich dass die
abgeordneten ihre mandate niederlegen
dann aber er wir sind jetzt haben sie
keine
erst als ich meine frage nicht
beantworten um eine wahl haben sie sorge
dass das auch die fdp betreffen wird wie
gesagt in ihrer partei gibt es viele die
nebentätigkeiten haben die auch gmbhs
haben glauben sie dass bei ihnen noch
was hoch bleibt nein ich habe diese
sorge nicht aber auch keinerlei
anhaltspunkte dafür
und das ist ja nicht vergleichbar ob
jemand eine nebentätigkeit hat oder ob
er in einer solchen situation wo die
nation in not ist und diese masken
braucht sich überlegt wie er daraus für
sich persönlich und privat ein
geschäftsmodell machen kann
und offensichtlich sind es ja keine
einzelfälle sonst hätten sich ja nicht
die fraktionsvorsitzenden schriftlich an
die abgeordneten gewandt
das heißt sie fordern einen
untersuchungsausschuss jetzt um das
ganze auf zu planen nein ich fordere
dass diese dinge aufgearbeitet werden
warum geld und drauf und csu fraktion
schlimm weil ihr zunächst einmal die
justiz die sachen aufarbeiten muss es
sind ja ermittlungsverfahren eingeleitet
und dann werden diese liegende
juristisch aufgearbeitet als nächstes
müssen wir so schnell wie möglich
natürlich konsequenzen haben damit das
vertrauen in die politik nicht
nachhaltig gestört wird das volk möchte
dass die abgeordneten die interessen des
volkes vertreten und nicht in ihre
eigene tasche wirtschaften und dann muss
natürlich auch geprüft werden was kann
so schnell wie möglich auf den weg
gebracht werden um die offensichtlichen
transparenz lücken des deutschen
bundestages aber draußen war
beispielsweise indem man ein
lobbyregister scharf warum vermuten sie
weitere fälle wissen haben sie da
anhaltspunkte
nein ich vermute das ist jedenfalls
seitens der fraktionsvorsitzenden von
cdu csu und eine sorge gibt es ansonsten
hätten sie sicher nicht an alle
abgeordneten mit einem schreiben gewandt
und auf die notwendigkeit hingewiesen in
einer solchen situation nicht an die
eigene tasche zu denken sondern an die
interessen der bevölkerung dieser briefe
hat mich etwas verwundert weil das
normalerweise ja selbstverständlich sein
sollte dass abgeordnete in einer so
schwierigen situation wenn sie etwas
vermitteln können an masken nicht daran
denken geld zu verdienen sondern daran
denken die dinge so schnell wie möglich
an die bedürftigen zu bringen
insofern ich habe keinen konkreten
verdacht nein aber mich erstaunt dieser
brief an alle abgeordnete
denn offensichtlich halten hält man
einen solchen brief ja seitens der
fraktionsführung der cdu csu fraktion
für erforderlich und jetzt müssen diese
dinge aufgeklärt werden das muss
transparenz geschaffen werden für die
gesamte politik ist da ein schwerer
schaden entstanden
wie gehen die frage weiter ab 17 jahren
den cdu-general es ihm lag sie sprechen
mit ihren leuten wahrscheinlich tag und
nacht um rauszufinden was es da noch
weitere es gibt was da noch hoch kommen
kann und was die union ja auch massiv
weiter schädigen kann was wissen sie und
was können sie uns erzählen was da in
ihrer partei in der fraktion in den
nächsten tagen noch explodiert also
ralph brinkhaus und alexander dobrindt
haben einen klaren und
unmissverständlichen brief an alle
abgeordneten geschrieben in dem klar
wurde
sowas wird nicht toleriert so was passt
auch nicht zu den moralischen ansprüchen
der cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion so was
passt nicht zu den moralischen auch
ansprüchen von cdu und csu also beider
parteien es gibt da eine null toleranz
sie sagen null toleranz aber es gibt ja
nicht nur einen plan a thai und führung
der fraktion und deswegen vertraue ich
genauso wie lars klingbeil das tut auf
bei seiner fraktion dass jedem klar ist
dass so etwas nicht geht also sind sie
jetzt sicher dass da nichts mehr kommt
sogar die menschen die die
die dort irgendwo beteiligt gewesen wäre
sind sie jetzt sicher sind sie sicher
dass da jetzt nichts mehr kommt bei
ihnen können sie da sagen wir haben alle
gefragt noch weitere skandale gibt es
nicht ich gehe davon aus dass jeder
abgeordnete die gleichen ansprüche an
sich stellt wie menschen das von uns
erwarten wir sind volksvertreter und wir
helfen auch in der krise wir vermitteln
kontakte aber halten nicht die hand auf
für die eigene tasche aber sind sie von
jedem sind sie sicher jedem auch innen
und erzieher sind sie sicher dass nicht
noch weitere abgeordnete die hand
aufgehalten haben
also bisher ist es ja so dass wir diese
beiden fälle haben und es gibt diese
klare ansage des fraktionsvorsitzenden
des landesgruppenchefs der csu und
insofern vertraue ich darauf dass alle
sich korrekt verhalten haben also das
heißt sie sind nicht sicher woher wissen
sie ich bin generalsekretär der cdu und
ich vertraue darauf dass alle
abgeordneten sich an die ansprüche
halten die wir uns alle selbst stellen
das ist doch logisch das ist doch in
meiner situation genau das gleiche wie
in der in der situation alle anderen
generalsekretäre die heute hier
zugeschaltet sie sprechen über vertrauen
in der politik der kellner hat sozusagen
schon angeteasert das während die
gesamte cdu die gesamte union über
korruptionsfälle über nebentätigkeit
gesprochen hat ein mann nominiert wurde
am wochenende der im vergangenen jahr
massiv in der kritik stand mit
nebentätigkeiten nämlich philipp am tor
er hat neben geschäfte gemacht mit
augustus intelligence und ausgerechnet
am gestrigen tag wurde er auf platz eins
der landesliste in mecklenburg
vorpommern dominiert das ist der platz
wo vorher die kanzlerin war herr
klingbeil was ist das für ein zeichen
was die cdu da setzt
ein ganz schlechtes und ein zeichnung
das komplett gegen die wie ich finde
richtigen unter ehrbaren worte von
meinem kollegen paul signac läuft da
muss man sich schon fragen welches
zeichen wird der gesetzt also jemand der
vor kurzer zeit auch noch den
korruptionsskandal um sich herum hatte
der auf nachweisbar auf kosten von
firmen unterwegs waren teuren hotels war
der auf seinem briefkopf des deutschen
bundestages werbung gemacht hat für ein
unternehmen das mag vielleicht alles
nicht strafbar gewesen sein aber das ist
alles sehr sehr unmoralisch was da
passiert ist und das zeichen das in
diesen tagen in dieser situation für die
union entsteht wenn eine solche person
direkt am nachfolger von angela merkel
an der spitze der landesliste in
mecklenburg-vorpommern war ich glaube
das schadet auch der politik und das
muss die union erklären warum man einen
solchen weg geht erziehen wir können sie
uns das erklären oder wurden sie auch
überrascht davon dass plötzlich der
philipp am tor auf platz eins nominiert
wurde jetzt vermischen sie fälle die
miteinander nichts zu tun haben nämlich
die fälle das aufhalten der eigenen hand
in dieser not krise als es um
schutzgüter ging und die fehler die
philipp an tor gemacht hat und philipp
am tor hat sofort eingeräumt es war ein
fehler
es war mindestens ein moralischer fehler
die generalstaatsanwaltschaft hat diesen
fall geprüft und ist zu der auffassung
gekommen dass nicht einmal ein
anfangsverdacht besteht die
bundestagsverwaltung hat den fall
eingehend geprüft hat sich alle
unterlagen zeigen dass uns zu dem
schluss gekommen
herrn am tor ist kein vorwurf zu machen
trotzdem wie ich finde zu recht hat er
gesagt es war ein fehler weil schon
alleine dieser eindruck entstanden ist
er hat auf den vorsitz der landesvorsitz
der cdu mecklenburg vorpommern
verzichtet er bereute es glaube ich am
meisten das aber überhaupt ging an
schnell wieder sein werk auch noch ein
tor in der union herr jeder mensch hat
eine zweite chance verdient sie sagen
eine zweite chance verdient ich möchte
ihnen einmal zeigen was der spiegel
-reporter kollege der das ganze mit
aufgedeckt hat heute getwittert hat und
zwar formuliert der
amthor hat nicht öffentlich beantwortet
wann genau er die aktienoptionen bekam
unklar blieb auch wenn die reisen
bezahlte und wie teuer diese waren der
sonst so beredte parlamentarier hat die
affäre ausgesessen und wird dafür jetzt
von seiner partei belohnt so scheint es
herr keller sie haben es gerade schon
angesprochen philipp am tor
wie sehen sie diesen fall und wenn da
nicht weiter aufgeklärt wird hat das
auch konsequenzen für eine mögliche
koalition mit der union nach der
bundestagswahl
und wir haben jetzt am wochenende zwei
landtagswahlen und ich finde es in
beiden landtagswahlen können die
wählerinnen und wähler eine antwort
geben und ich habe das gefühl in beiden
ländern ist die union schlagbar und ich
finde das ist auch die richtige antwort
offensichtlich ist die union zu lange an
der macht sonst ist es sind einfach zu
viele einzelfälle und wir sehen ja auch
an der geschichte der union immer wieder
die schwarzen kassen von helmut kohl mag
ich hier einmal daran erinnern und diese
punkte zeigt ja offensichtlich das ist
ein kulturelles einhaltung problem zu
der frage von korruption geht und
deswegen ist es nicht nur gut werden
merkt dass verurteilt sein noch besser
wäre wenn wir ins handeln kommen und
wenn wir die entsprechenden gesetzlichen
regelungen im deutschen bundestag
verabschieden die eine höhere
transparenz erzielen
herzberg die frage an sie warum machen
sie nicht einfach was warum sagen sie
nicht ja wir müssen das hertha begrenzen
ich meine es ist erst vor wenigen tagen
oder vor einer woche raus gekommen dass
ihr minister jens spahn 9.999 euro
sozusagen aufgefordert hat das
unternehmer diese spenden vor einem
dinner finden sie das eigentlich okay
wenn da solche summen wo klar ist dass
das ganze erst ab 10.000 euro angegeben
werden muss finden sie nicht dass es
dafür klare linien geben muss einfach
nebentätigkeiten ganz klar
aufgezählt also mir ist nicht bekannt
dass iren sparen irgendwie ihn
aufgefordert hat 9.999 euro zu spenden
das ist jetzt eine neue nein nein da
wollen sie nein nein er ziemlich falsch
verstanden ich habe seitdem zusammen
mit dem spenden dinner hat der gastgeber
im vorfeld nach unseren informationen
dazu aufgefordert diese 9100 99 euro zu
spenden zu spenden aber die spenden war
natürlich für den kreisverband in borken
ja es gibt eine regel also ab 10.000
euro wird veröffentlicht in welcher höhe
jemand an eine parteispende egal an
welche gliederung so bin ich es gewohnt
entscheidet immer derjenige der spendet
so ist die rechtslage und so erwarte ich
dass auch von jedem und den sachverhalt
fort ich war da nicht dabei ich kenne
auch nicht dieser vorhaltung die dort
gemacht werden aber der führen die
menschen sich doch komplett hinters
licht geführt oder wenn man sagt okay ab
10.000 muss man das angeben und einige
spenden da 9.999 euro um das eben nicht
anzugeben das ist zerstört doch gerade
dieses vertrauen in die politik hat sie
mir ja die also die höhe die der spenden
ab wann ein name veröffentlicht wird das
ist ja schon vor langer zeit geregelt
worden sagt ihnen ganz offen und sie
finden es cool relativ egal wie hoch
dieser höhe ist also sie werden auch
bereit das ganze abzusenken und zusagen
auch alle spenden unter 10.000 euro
sollten dann angegeben werden ja
natürlich können wir darüber sprechen es
gibt ja das ist ja eine eine zahl die
festgelegt wurde
herr wissing werden sie auch dafür dass
stadt verändern kein naturgesetz habe
das ist ja spannend hält ziemlich
spricht sich dafür aus spenden auch
unter 10.000 euro zu veröffentlichen
werden sie auch dabei wenn du auf jeden
fall dafür dass man das auch überprüft
ich halte diesen vorfall auch für
schwierig wenn bei einem spenden die da
jeder 9.999 euro spendet und das ganze
offensichtlich genau auf diese summe
festgelegt wird um so viel wie möglich
so intransparent wie
wirklich zu spenden das ist nicht gut
und nach diesen vorfällen jetzt müssen
wir sowieso die regeln überprüfen so
kann man nicht weitermachen das sind
keine das ist ja nicht einfach sondern
das sind mehrere fälle und deswegen
bedarf es hier strengerer regeln das
muss schnell kommen
wir haben sonst einen ganz schnellen
vertrauensverlust die situation ist
finde ich sehr sehr ernst wir haben
jetzt eine situation dem volk geht es
nicht gut diese corona pandemie verlangt
den menschen enorm wichtig da wollen wir
da wollen wir da ich habe gleich
aufzurufen ist das letzte da wollen wir
gleich darauf zurückkommen auf das
vertrauen aber ich möchte schnell um
hier eine entscheidung herbeizuführen so
zu sagen weil die richtigen fragen dass
man sich einig dass anzugehen daher
klingbeil sind sie auch dafür dass das
abgesenkt werden sollte wir sind da
sofort gesprächsbereit und muss auch
sagen naja gesprächsbereiter klima was
ist denn jetzt ihre positionen sind sie
dafür oder dagegen
er war bei uns stimmt man im
kreisvorstand schon über eine spende von
1000 euro ab ob man die handels- oder
nicht insofern habe ich kein problem
damit wenn spenden früher veröffentlicht
werden wir haben dann nicht zu
verstecken das muss nachvollziehbar dass
muss transparent das muss für die
bevölkerung zugänglich sein also null
problem ich will aber die noch mal
betonen wir haben jetzt endlich eine
einigung zum lobbyregister ja aber mich
interessiert gerade das thema klingbeil
und deswegen würde ich gerne mal alle da
würde ich gerne mal jetzt alle
generalsekretäre die sich dafür
aussprechen dass die summe auch unter
10.000 euro veröffentlicht werden soll
einmal die hand heben bitte
das zugesagte einmal die an themen als
sie herrn ich sehe auch die jagd und da
sich ein kellner und der klingbeil was
es mit ihnen
ich habe die hand gehoben und sie haben
die hand gehoben also hiermit
beschlossen
bei bild die richtigen fragen meine
damen und herren das ist eigentlich eine
ein historischer schritt kann man sagen
die vier generalsekretäre der
wichtigsten parteien haben sich gerade
eben dafür ausgesprochen dass künftig
auch unter 10.000 euro
das ganze angegeben wird ich hoffe dass
sie dann auch vor der bundestagswahl
noch darüber sprechen wollen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren